it's interesting because i think the the
in game of thrones
that uh idea of leaving people wanting
more is
is a constant thing and there's also the
idea of
you know game of thrones in the books uh
uh you know songs of ice and fire
are not like other books that one might
compare them to or other shows
they they often break the conventions of
the very genre that
then one might assign them uh to how
does that play into how you
you write well you know i've always
liked breaking conventions
i mean i i love the genres i'm i'm not
one of these guys who's trying to burn
everything down with a flamethrower i i
love science fiction i love fantasy
but i hate familiarity i i love uh
whether i'm watching television
or going to a film or reading a book i i
want it
to surprise me i don't want to know
where it was heading you know
maybe i get that from my childhood with
my mother i mean we would sit at home
watching tv
as a family and my mother would always
say aloud
exactly what was going to happen oh it's
the butler who killed him
and sure enough it would be the butler
who killed him you know you know she
would uh you know be watching i love
lucy and oh that belt is going to start
going much faster she's not going to be
able to keep
up with the chocolates and
yeah sure enough that would happen so i
learned pretty early the trick of
watching these shows and predicting that
where we were where they were going to
go
the one we she couldn't predict of
course maybe was one reason i loved this
so much was the original twilight zone
which is famous twist endings
it's hard for for uh you know a crowd uh
looking around i see a lot of young
people here in this audience and
um to to know what a revolutionary
show twilight zone was in 1959 and 1960
and
how surprising those twist endings were
uh when we revived twilight zone in the
mid 80s you know the network was always
on us one of one of the
things we had on that show is why can't
you have more twist endings as as the
original show did
and we tried man but you know what
worked in 1959 really did not work in
1986
i i tell you you know people the
audience had become so much more
sophisticated
and they could see those twist endings
coming a mile away you know it's the
minute somebody walks into the store and
says she's a mannequin
yeah of course she's a better kid
[Laughter]
the minute you know you don't show the
face of a bandage characters oh she's
the they're all the ugly ones haven't
you noticed that they're not showing
their faces
yeah you know these great techniques
that ron serling invented in 59
in the ensuing 20 30 years had become
so familiar to the audiences you
couldn't put it over on them anymore
so coming up with a with a really
genuine twist ending that worked
became harder and harder
someone should tell that to m knight
uh and he should he should drop trying
for those
twist endings